Podcast UFO, hier ist ja fantastisch. Vielen, vielen Dank, Philipp. Gibt es einen besseren Einstieg in den Tag zu kommen als so ein Intro? Es ist grandios. Du hast sofort gute Laune, du bist sofort drin, es ist herrlich ein wunderbarer Tag. Und für die, die gerade einschlafen, gibt es einen schöneren Tag, den Moment den Tag zu beenden. Es ist nie zu spät, den Tag zu einem guten Tag zu machen. Das ist meine Devise. Es ist auch nie zu spät, den Tag zu beginnen oder irgendwas Bescheures zu machen. Ich sage mal, alle Zuschauer hier, Zuschauerinnen sind ja erwachsen. Ich glaube, wir haben mehr Hörerinnen als Zuschauer, um ganz ehrlich zu sein. Aber viele starren auch einfach unser Logo an, weil sie sich denken, liegt es an mir oder ist es unscharf oder was ist da los? Ne, das stimmt schon, Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und ein Kumpel von mir hat mal gesagt, er konnte nachts nicht schlafen, wegen einer Krankheit gedöhnt und so. Und dann ist er aufgestanden. Verdammte Leukämie, verdammte, ich kann das nicht mehr, ich halte das nicht mehr aus. Und ist dann nachts, einfach mitten in der Nacht eine Runde spazieren gegangen. Oh ja. Und er hat mir das gesagt und ich glaube, da hat mein Mind so einen Jump gemacht, sondern ich war plötzlich in anderen Sphären, plötzlich wurde mein Bewusstsein erweitert. Ah, das kann man ja machen. Ich kann ja, ich bin ja erwachsen. Ich muss ja nicht meinen Eltern sagen, was machst du denn jetzt mitten in der Nacht, schießt deine Schuhe an mit dem großen Schuhlöffel im Flur. Ich glaube, es dauert bis zum Ende des Lebens, um zu realisieren, dass man kein Kind mehr ist. Dass man Dinge ja wirklich auch einfach machen darf. Ich könnte ja alles machen. Ist vielleicht doof. Also das habe ich jetzt auch nicht hinterfragt. Ich habe bis heute noch nicht hinterfragt, ob es eine gute Idee ist, nachts im Kalten spazieren zu gehen oder wenn es Sommernacht war. Das kann jetzt auch nicht geholfen. Andere andere Seite. Erwachsenen ist auch Verantwortung nehmen. Aber man kann halt auch erst mal machen, was man will. Und das fände ich total toll. Dieses, geht doch einfach mal nachts eine Runde spazieren. Und da kann man bestimmt gut schlafen. Trefft euch. Ich habe meinen Tag eigentlich schon durchgespielt heute, perfekt. Denn kann man sagen, wir nehmen sehr früh morgens auf. Merkt man an unseren Stimmchen. Dass wir gerade aus dem Decken geschlüpft sind. Die Decken sind noch warm und wir auch. Denn ich habe heute wahrscheinlich das erste Mal in meinem Leben gesehen, wie ein Springbrunnen angegangen ist. Nein, das glaube ich jetzt nicht. Also ich kam da an, setzte mich an den herrlichen Residenzteich, das ist ja bei uns vorm Westflügel, wir haben ja da dieses komplette Labyrinthgartensystem, da haben wir auch einen künstlichen See installieren lassen. Und im Sommer gibt es ja einmal den Tag der offenen Tür, wo alle kommen können. Genau. Sonst sind Gäste generell nicht so gerne gesehen. Das stimmt. Leider haben wir es mit dem Gartenlabyrinth ein bisschen übertrieben. Es gehen immer weniger Leute als kommen. Viele Leute verirren sich da und verenden dann kläglich im Efeu. Aber ich habe neulich auch mal irgendwie gesehen, dass da sich eine Gruppe formiert hat, also ein paar Gangs formiert haben, die beschlossen haben, darin weiterzuleben. Ja, das stimmt, da hinten bei diesem Betonfuchs, der eigentlich den Weg weisen sollte. Da ist so eine Amazone, steht da irgendwo, ist so geschnitzt aus diesem Hecken-Ding. Ach toll. Und da hinten habe ich die auch gesehen, also da wahrscheinlich gibt es mehrere Orte. Lass uns das doch mal eine Weile beobachten und uns dann als deren Gottheit präsentieren, oder? Ja, ja. Gut, haben wir das. Aber ich saß am See, dachte mir natürlich wie immer Springboden aus, so wie es sich gehört. Die werden installiert, dann laufen sie 20 Minuten, dann schwimmt da irgendein Fisch rein und dann ist das erste Mal Schluss für die nächsten 400 Jahre. Dann Algenpanik und dann weg. Und dann saß ich da und plötzlich mir nichts, dir nichts, außerdem nichts. Ich war genauso schockiert wie die Enten, die genau da saßen im Wasser. Bats, ging plötzlich der Springbrunnen an, Fontänen in die Luft, fünf Meter hoch. Die Enten dachten sich, what the fuck ist jetzt los? Was geschieht hier um mich herum? Ich war erquickt, habe mich gefreut, die Enten reißaus, also so joggendes.
Am Reißaus genommen.
Ja, aber ich weiß gar nicht, wie schnell Enten wirklich maximal schwimmen können. Ich habe das Gefühl, selbst wenn Enten in Lebensgefahr wegschwimmen, ist es immer noch so ein lockeres Joggen.
Was ich jetzt gedacht hatte, dass sie wegfliegen.
Nein.
Beruhig dich, beruhig dich, beruhig dich. Eine Ente hat versucht, die Flügel zu spannen, alle Enten so langsam, langsam, okay? Es ist nur Wasser. Das ist ein Schwimmproblem. Es ist im Prinzip das, was wir schon auch mögen. Bei Enten geht es immer, ist es ein Schwimmproblem oder ist es ein Flugproblem? Also ist es ein schweres Problem oder können wir noch schwimmen? Genau, auch hier die Frage, was ranken sie höher? Wasser, welches Element, sind die eher Wasser- oder Luftfans? Das ist das alte Problem, wenn die grossen Elementaristenkriege aufbrechen, dann müssen die Stellung beziehen. Die Enten müssen sich Stellung beziehen, wohingegen bei vielen Leuten ist es klar. Ja, Maulwurf, Maulwurf safe. Bei self-Feuer. Feuer ist ein bisschen dünn besetzt, hätte ich gesagt. Es gibt den Feuersalamander. Ja, gibt Glurak. Das stimmt, stimmt. Ist Feuer Salamander, jetzt wo du es sagst. Ach so. Glumander ist der Feuer Salamander. Ah ja, ja. Glumander. Glumander. Salamander. Mhm. Feuer Salamander. Wow. Aber warum ist der Feuer Salamander? Ist der irgendwie einfach nur warm? Nee, der hat hinten so ein paar Flammen quasi draufgesprayt.
Nee, das ist eher wie so Airbrush, was man von der Kirmes kennt.
Ah, cool. Das ist hinten auf so einem Fall.
Bisschen oldschoolig.
Der ist eigentlich schwarz, aber hat so gelbe, orangene Flammen drauf.
Ja.
Das ist ja eigentlich das coolste Tier.
Also so für Kinder.
Wirklich das coolste Tier.
Irgendwann wird es, also ich finde es persönlich jetzt inzwischen kitschig.
Früher als Kind fand ich das ein schönes Tier.
Es sieht aus wie so ein Matchbox-Auto einfach.
Ja, genau.
Es sieht einfach richtig cool flammenhaft aus. Genau, ja. Nicht mehr so cool, wenn sie dann in so einem Skimmer von so einem Teich hängen. Ja. Davor sehr cool. Oder einfach von einem angehenden Springbrunnen 40 Meter die Luft geschossen werden. So, was ist das denn? Aber es wäre lustig, wenn die ins Wasser springen und dann so ein bisschen Rauch hochsteigt. Oh ja. Und das macht so ein TfSachen. Aber das ist so. Die können die ja selber machen. Und dann geht so ein bisschen, das wären sie gelöscht worden vom Wasser. Das fände ich ja toll. Das fände ich ja toll. Aber wir können es ja verraten, also so offen sind wir. Ich glaube, es war Punkt zehn Uhr. Es war Punkt zehn Uhr, dass der Springbronn anging. Das heißt, jetzt mal für alle Urlosen unter euch, die sich versuchen, an der Umgebung zu orientieren und zu Hause sein müssen, wenn die Strassenlaternen angehen, was ein tolles System ist. Und jetzt könnt ihr euch auch weiter daran orientieren, Springbrunnen gehen um 10 Uhr morgens an, also ihr könnt sagen, dann gehe ich aus dem Haus, wenn die Springbrunnen ansehen. Aber hat das nicht bei dir dazu geführt, dass du an Ort gegangen bist, wo keine Laternen waren, wenn du zu Hause sein musst, wenn die Laternen angehen, was eigentlich dich in die Hände von Pederasten treibt, weil wo sind die denn, wo suchen die nach hinten und da, wo keine Laternen sind wahrscheinlich? Ja, das stimmt. Ich war viel im Wald und da habe ich die Laternen nicht gesehen. Das war dann immer die Ausrede, warum man zu spät nach Hause kam. Ich habe die Laternen nicht gesehen. Ah, da bin ich bis in den Wald gelaufen. Ich bin tief, tief in den Wald.
Ah genau, ja, das auch nicht machen.
Ich habe ein Loch gegraben, habe mich da reingelegt
und dann habe ich leider nicht gesehen, dass die Laternen angekommen sind.
Ja, das ja auch nicht machen, Florentin.
Ja, aber da müssen wir vielleicht deine Regeln ein bisschen überarbeiten, Mutter.
Ja, dann komm nach Hause, ich will dir aber auch keine Uhr geben.
Wie verlierst du nämlich?
Du hast recht, du hast recht.
Ich glaube, hätte ich eine Uhr, würde ich den ganzen Tag nur auf die Uhr schauen
und mich gar nicht mehr auf meine Kindheit konzentrieren und die genießen, so wie es ein Kind sollte. Ja, du hängst ja nur an deiner Uhr. Was machen Flick und Flack? Ja, aber es kommt nur noch eine Stunde, Mama. Nein! Nur noch eine Stunde auf die Uhr gucken. Du bist ein merkwürdiges Kind, du starrst nur auf die Uhr die ganze Zeit. Bitte nur bis zehn nach, nur bis zehn nach, bitte. Okay, bis zehn nach. Eine Stunde noch. Okay. Er starrt wieder nur aufs Scheiss-Uhr. Aber es ist eine gute Uhr. Es ist eine schöne Uhr. Ich habe damals, weiß ich, noch 90 Mark gespart, um mir eine Uhr zu kaufen. Und die habe ich in deiner rechten Hand getragen. In deiner rechten Hand hast du die getragen? Es war so eine Taschenuhr, die mit so einem Bun an meinem Scout-Rucksack befestestigt war. Also weirder Mix an Zeiten, aber trotzdem sehr, sehr nützlich und ich habe sie immer rechts getragen, weswegen ich eigentlich meine ganze Kindheit für Linkshänder gehalten wurde und dahingehend immer unterschätzt wurde. Und deswegen konnte ich immer auftrumpfen. Mit einer unglaublich talentierten, dann doch talentierten rechten Hand. In jeder Schulhofschlägerei dachten die, ah ja, ich sehe schon, da kommt jetzt gleich eine Linke und ich, aber nein, da kommt nur wegrennen und weinen von rechts. Aber kamst du nicht mehr plus minus null raus, weil du gewissermaßen, klar mit der rechten hast du begeistert, mit der linken hast du enttäuscht, wenn man dich für einen Linkslander hält, du aber Rechtslander bist?
Du, ich habe gelernt, man muss Kämpfe möglichst schnell entscheiden.
Ah, okay, du meinst den Überraschungseffekt. Das ist alles für den Überraschungseffekt. Genau, wirklich leg deine gesamte Kraft. Achtsig, lad auch gerne mal auf. Halt A gedrückt, halt auch gerne den Schlag mal aufladen und dann einfach einen Schlag ausgenockt und weglaufen. Weil lang halte ich es eh nicht aus. Ich finde gut, dass du aber vorher so deinen Gegnern auf dem Schulhof, die ja auch dann so um die zwölf Jahre alt waren, so eine Sherlock-artige Beobachtungsgabe unterstellst, der dann erstmal scannt von oben bis unten und dann kommen so kleine Pfeile und dann sieht er Uhr an der rechten Hand, also Linkshänder. Oh, ich muss eine starke linke Hand erwarten. Abdrücke an den Ohren, er ist eigentlich Brillenträger, das heißt, er sieht nicht gut. Wenn ich mich von hinten anschleiche, kriege ich ihn vielleicht. Müde, rote Augen, wahrscheinlich hat er die ganze Zeit auch die Uhr geschaut. Es sind wahrscheinlich die wichtigsten Kämpfe der Welt auf dem Schulhof, wenn du da einmal gewinnst, bist du der krasseste Typ. So war es bei uns dann nicht mehr. Nee, ich war noch in meinem Leben in der Kämpferei. Das sind genau diese Jahre, die uns trennen. Bei euch waren noch diese Kämpfe. Ja, wir hatten noch so lange Ketten, so schwingende Ketten und Sensen auf dem Schulhof. Ja, ja. Ihr dann Pokémon-Karten. Da war es eine andere Art von Kampf. Genau, wir haben Pokémon, wir haben die Glumandas und Gluraks die Kämpfe austragen lassen für uns. Ne, wir haben das noch selber gemacht. Schön einfach mit so einer Bekstange. Schön Tackle. Irgendwann kamen dann diese grossen Schlösser, da hatten dann alle Fahrräder diese grossen Schlösser, dieses lange U. und das war die Primärwaffe eigentlich, weil das konnte man legal immer dabei haben und jeder hatte so ein paar davon, eins um das Fahrrad tatsächlich abzuschliessen, aber eins im Rucksack und dann hat sich ein ganz eigener Kampfstil entwickelt, wie man diese langen Schlösser dann irgendwie versucht hat als Waffe einzusetzen, was glaube ich in vielen mittelalterlichen Abhandlungen gar nicht als Primärwaffe gedacht war, musste man jetzt improvisieren, wie man mit diesem grossen Schloss denn am besten umgeht, mit diesem kreisartigen Gebilde. Ach so, ich habe ja so eine grosse Kette, die natürlich ist natürlich aber viel zu gefährlich. Also, what? Holy shit, da kann man ja auch für sich noch schießen, dann ist das Gleiche. Ich glaube,ächste, was ich jemals an der Schlägerei war, war, dass der Coolste bei mir in der Klasse gesagt hat, ach, du machst Karate, schlag mich mal. Weil irgendwann hat er sich rumgesprochen oder man hat es an meinem weissen Outfit gesehen, dass ich Karate mache. Und dann hat er gesagt, ach, du machst Karate, ja, dann schlag mich mal. Und das Karate gesagt. Und dann hat er gesagt, ein wahrer Karate-Karate. Wer war der Coolste aus der Klasse und was macht er heute? Oh, das weiß ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht. Ich habe ihn aus den Augen verloren, aber vielleicht sehe ich ihn irgendwann nochmal. Und dann schlägst du ihn in die Fresse. Es gab ja mehrere coole Leute in den verschiedenen Jahrgängen, aber da in der ersten, fünften Klasse, erste Klasse Gymnasium war schon ganz klar, Roman ist der coolste. Roman. So einfach krasseste Typ. Mir fällt gerade auf, dass ich gerade, worüber Pokémon geträumt habe heute Nacht, dass mir jemand sagt, nee, du kannst nicht nur ein cooles Accessoire tragen, ein extrovertiertes Accessoire. Ich mag, dass deine Träume so kritisch sind, dass er wirklich hart ins Gericht gegangen wird. Mega nervig, der Traum. Du kannst nicht nur ein cooles Accessoire tragen, ich glaube, es war auf eine coole Sonnenbrille oder so was Weirdes bezogen, dann siehst du aus, das ist eher so wie ein Pokémon. Du musst mehr Sachen tragen. Ich verstehe. Und ich habe es in einer Art verstanden. Ich fand es weird, das war ich noch aufgewacht von Weirdness aufgewacht. Du darfst dich nicht auf eine Sache reduzieren lassen. Aber wenn du, ich verstehe schon, Pol Polenta hat die Lauchstange. Genau, Knogger hat die Knochenkopf. Genau, alle haben so ein Ding, so ein Accessoire, dann bist du so Pokémon-haftig. Wenn ich jetzt dann so eine, so eine grosse weirde Brille mit so Spinnennetz trage oder sowas, dann bin ich, dann ist man direkt so Pokémon-artig ne, spitz. Wo kommt dieses innere Feedback her in deinem Traum? Das habe ich mich auch gefragt. Ist es ein Teil von dir, der sagt ... Das riecht so lustig. Oder ist es deine Coolness, die langsam erwacht, oder wie ist es? Ich weiß nicht. Was redet da mit mir? Ich bin doch ich, dachte ich immer. Es ist merkwürdig. Ich hatte einen extrem langen Traum. Ich weiß nicht, ob dir das mit mir auch so vorkommt, dass manche Traum extrem Überlänge mit Pause. Ich habe mir noch mal Popcorn geholt. Ja, ja. Und zwar habe ich ellenlang geträumt, wie ich Kehlkopfgesang lerne, weil ich mir dachte, wenn ich Kehlkopfgesang beherrsche, kann ich ja gleichzeitig noch Beatboxen. Das war meine Überlegung.
Und dann habe ich Stunden genommen, Unterricht genommen, Kehlkopf, wie macht man das, Tonhöhe, eine Stunde nach der anderen, ich bin da immer hingegangen, mit dem Bus, an die Stelle gefahren, dahin, ich habe locker sieben Stunden Gesangsunterricht geträumt.
Und acht Stunden im Bus gesessen. Und dann bin ich aufgewacht und konnte gar nichts. Was soll das denn? Ich habe mir acht Stunden genommen. Und ich bin aufgewacht und natürlich in diesem kurzen, schönen Moment des Mäh und jetzt einfach Nee, das habe ich nur geträumt. Du hast Kehlkopf-Gesangsunterricht genommen. Genau, Kehlkopf. Weil, wie gesagt, meine Idee war, dann gleichzeitig noch Beatboxen zu können. Aber das habe ich dann auch nicht gelernt. Ich habe nur den Kehlkopf gelernt. Ich habe ja nicht verstanden, ob das geht. Weil Kehlkopfgesang ist ja schon auch eine allumfassende Tätigkeit dann, oder? Meist du nicht, dass es relativ speziell nur der Kehlkopf übernimmt? Und der Kehlkopf sagt, ich hab das, okay, ich mach das, Leute.
Leute, Stimmbänder, setzt euch hin.
Handbügel, bügel du ruhig, Mund macht Beatbox, wie anders.
Haare, ihr wachst wie immer, ihr macht alles wie gehabt, ich sing jetzt was Schönes.
Und die Lippen sagen ...
Das ist jetzt aber ...
Naja, ich verstehe, was ihr denkt. Wir haben noch gerade über Kehlkopfgesang gesprochen.
Jetzt kommt's. Es ist schön, es ist toll, aber ich glaube, Fun. Aber sowas, also das finde ich nicht... So ungefähr habe ich mir das vorgestellt. Freut mich, dass wir meinen kleinen Traum jetzt hier auch nachstellen konnten. Und ja, so wäre das gegangen, wenn ich nicht einfach geschlafen hätte während allen Stunden, sondern es tatsächlich gemacht hätte. Naja, aber wie gesagt, Tony Hawk oder nicht, der einzige Skateboard, der mir einfällt. Aber einer hat doch einen berühmten Skateboard, der hat doch auch nach einer Verletzung noch weiter gelernt im Traum. Also sollen wir jetzt mal, ist das jetzt ein neuer Ansatz für uns, wir tun das, was wir träumen? Also weil irgendjemand irgendwas sagt uns ja bitte in leeren Kehlkopfgesang. Welche Stimme ist es in dir, die sagt, nee, mach mal was? Die sagt leeren Kehlkopfgesang. Die sagt, raus da. Es ist ja oft so, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit relativ hoch ist, dass man das, was man richtig gut kann, gar nicht macht. Also vielleicht bin ich der beste Surfer der Welt, nur nie gemacht.
Und vielleicht sind diese Träume eine Art, deines Körpers zu sagen,
so jetzt ist er über 30, jetzt machen wir langsam mal die Box auf.
Ich behaupte, das gibt es gar nicht.
Ich glaube, du bist in nichts, was du noch nie gemacht hast,
und dann meine ich jetzt nicht genau das gemacht hast,
sondern was Ähnliches, bist du nicht gut drin.
Es gibt, ihr habt alle keine, das schraubt die Fomo ein bisschen runter und die Angst, dass man im Leben was anderes machen sollte. Nein, man ist immer keine versteckten Skills in etwas, was man nicht so ähnlich, angenommen, du bist jetzt gut, wenn du sagst, du bist Longboard- Fahrer und so und bist super gut, darin Balance zu halten oder bist auf diesem Wackelbrett, bist du der King. Dann sehe ich dich auch an der Algarve
surfen. Was mit Pavarotti?
Der hat doch auch erst mit 40 angefangen zu singen.
Davor hat er viel gesprochen.
Mein Sprechen ist so eine Art Vorbereitung zu singen.
Ja.
Ich habe auch schon meine Blume gegossen und deswegen bin ich nicht gut im Gärtnern.
Oder ich habe schon meine
Nähmene Wien gesehen und deswegen kann ich nicht gut imkern. Vielleicht bist du der beste Imker der Welt. Das kann ich mir allerdings schon auch vorstellen. Diese Regel trifft auf alle zu, ausser bei mir. Ich habe viele versteckte Talente. Das redet man sich dann selber so. Vor allem, wir waren ja jetzt unterwegs gerade in Wien. Dafür war ich auch so ein bisschen in der Heimat unterwegs, im Süden Deutschlands und war ein bisschen spazieren. Und dann, glaube ich, war der furchteinflussendste ein Anblick, den man überhaupt nur haben kann. Ich bin so einen Feldweg entlang gegangen und mir entgegen kamen zwei Typen in so Imkeranzügen. Und man denkt sich so, fuck, ich bin hier weit und weit der einzige, der nicht diesen hochtechnologischen Schutzanzug anhat. Und man fühlt sich einfach schlecht, du fühlst dich schutzlos, du fühlst dich nackt, du fühlst deine weichen Fleischlappen einfach völlig entblösst gegenüber den spitzen Stacheln der Bienen. Ja genau, wir hatten noch über Anpassungsfähigkeit mal gesprochen des Menschen. Wo ist jetzt mit meinen durchstechbaren blöden Hautläppchen? Es kann sein, dass eines Tages ein Kind geboren wird, das einfach standardmäßig so einen Imkeranzug mit drin hat. Und dann muss man nur sagen, jetzt musst du dich aber bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte schnell weiterentwickeln. Ich hätte aufs Handy geguckt, ob da so eine Notstandsmeldung gekommen wäre. Oh, gibt es eine ... So, bitte begeben Sie sich sofort in Bienenschutzanzüge. Und auf der App so eine Wolke. So eine Wolke gekommen. So eine Wolke, die so ganz schnell den hat. Ja. Gibt es da eine App, Honey oder so, wo man Bienen in der Nähe Hilfe ... Es gibt doch Leute, die tödlich allergisch gegen Bienenstiche sind, oder? Gibt es da nicht eine App, die sagt, wo Bienen in der Nähe sind? Beware oder sowas? Beware. Ja. Bee-App. Sowas in der Richtung, dass man einfach weiß, wo es ist? Nee, aber es gibt auch diese App, die einem sagt, was gerade los ist an furchtbaren Meldungen. Twitter? Nee, wie heißt denn nochmal diese App? Nina, die Warn-App, die Warn-App vom Katastrophenschutz. Und da fände ich da auch nicht so schlecht, wenn da zwischendurch mal so kleinere Probleme auch noch kommen. Ja, Frettchen, Frettchen in der Nähe, Frettchen in 50 Meter Nähe, Vorsicht, Vorsicht Fuchs, hüpp, einmal jetzt in Springen in drei Sekunden hoch. Und wir haben es geschafft. Aber es ist nicht so schlecht, weil man mag das, also natürlich, jetzt nicht falsch verstehen, aber man hat natürlich so einen sensationalistischen Charakter in sich, dass wenn so eine Meldung kommt, man kurz denkt, oh cool, ich bin in einer Art Film. Danger, Danger. Danger, Danger, cool, und man ist in so einem Überlebens-Survival-Action-Film-Modus. Da fände ich jetzt nicht so schlecht, ehrlich gesagt, wenn da mal so eine Meldung kommen würde, die das Gefühl auslöst, aber nicht schlimm ist. Zum Beispiel, wow, krass, drei Bienen, ne, aber ich muss ein bisschen aufpassen. Du verstehst, was ich mache. Vorsicht, eine hat nichts zu verlieren. Eine wurde gerade verlassen und ist bereit zu stechen. Eine wurde vom Volk ausgewiesen. Eine hat einen lockeren Stachel, wenn du verstehst, was ich meine. Die wird heute Nacht noch zum Zug kommen. Was ist das für eine App? Jesus Christ. Nina. Nina. Nina. Das ist aber auch die dümmste Ausrede. Nina. Wer ist eigentlich Nina? Nina, das ist eine App, die diese Gefahrennachrichten mir immer schickt. Nina schickt dir jeden Tag Nachrichten. Ja, ja, ja, ja, nee, nee, nee, nee, das ist eine App, die schickt mir, wenn ein Vulkanausbruch ist oder so. Okay, und warum folgst du da auch bei Instagram? Damit ich einfach weiss, weil da sieht man dann Bilder von einer Landkarte, wo der Vulkan und wo die Lava hingeht. Okay, wir wohnen in Köln. Ja. Na gut, aber die Eifel kann ausbrechen. Warum holst du deinen Stachel raus? Jetzt ist alles egal.
Jetzt ist alles egal.
Wie fucking dramatisch das Leben einer Biene ist, die zu jeder Zeit denkt, ich steck den jetzt und zieh uns beide in den Tod.
Glaubst du, in der Bienenwelt gibt es so diesen Mythos, dass es mal eine geschafft hat, zu stechen und hat überlebt?
Ja, das kann das...
Die Biene, die überlebt hat?
Oder eine Biene, die zwei Stacheln hat. Oh ja. Die als einzige zweimal stichen darf. Das ist schon geil. Bisschen Lame für den Film. Ja. So wie alle hätten so eine Jack-Sparrow-Kugel, die einmal ist mehr und eine hat zwei. Ja, lass uns dem folgen, der einen Schuss mehr hat. Lass uns dem folgen, dessen Taten am wenigsten Risiko beinhalten. Genau, dessen Steaks ein bisschen geringer sind. Das ist das andere Figur. Genau, weil er könnte ja einmal daneben schießen. Und es wäre immer noch alles okay. Er wäre dann erst da, wo alle anderen sind. Lass uns der Figur folgen, die mit weniger Fallhöhe. Aber glaubst du, es gibt da so einen Mythos? Die Biene, die überlebt hat? Ich glaube schon, ja. Wir wirklich so eine Überbiene, Dagi Bee oder so die Königin oder sowas, die einfach die, die überlebt hat. Die denn ohne Stachel unterwegs war, die denn niemand mehr ernst genommen hat oder so. Von den Machern vom Jungen, der überlebt hat. Harry Potter, Trademark. Die Biene, die überlebt. Die Biene, die eine Biene, die überlebt hat. Ein deutlich schlechteres Franchise, Ohne Magie. Aber schöner Bucheinwand. Aber schöner Bucheinwand. Schönes Felschmack. Und gibt es da auch die vier Häuser in dem Bienenstock? Ja, die vier verschiedenen Honigsorten, oder? Warum einfach mal die Top vier der Honigsorten? Ja, selbstverständlich. Auf Platz vier der Top vier Honigsorten ist der Akazienhonig. Auf Platz drei.
Wie du das nicht googeln, Stefan.
Haben wir Probierset Honig.
Auf Platz zwei, die flotte Biene.
Auf Platz drei, Genussreise Honig Schätze sechsteilig.
Ja, wenn ich Honigsorten google, warum sind das dann die ersten beiden Dinge?
Auf Platz Nummer eins, Agavendicksaft.
Auf Platz zwei zwei Nutella.
Ich habe die Kategorie vergessen. Aber mit diesem coolen Honiglöffel. Kennst du diesen Honiglöffel, diesen Kolben, der selber wiederum aussieht wie ein Bienenstock? Ist das denn ein Zufall? Also dass genau das Objekt, das man am besten benutzen kann, diese physikalische Viskositätsmasse Honig, die die Menschheit nie unter Kontrolle bekommen hat, bis irgendjemand gesagt hat, hier ist es, hier ist es, hier ist dieses Holzteil, mit dem man das so aufrollen kann, wie so ein Dönerspieß oder was auch immer das ist. Naja, es ist ja auch in Schichten, ne? Also du hast ja auch dann quasi Löcher dazwischen, Spalten dazwischen. Und dadurch hängt sich das mehr auf. Du kannst quasi richtig viel Flüssigkeit, Honigflüssigkeit aufnehmen. Ja. Und ja, ich glaube aber, es ist Bullshit. Ich glaube, das in einer anderen Form wäre noch besser. Man hat sich aber dann gesagt, komm, jetzt damit alles einheitlich aussieht. Man will ja mal alles einheitlich haben, gestreamlined haben. Du meinst, es ist nur ein PR-Gag, dass das so aussieht wie ein Riesenhoax. Du meinst du wie Bärchensalami? Wie PR-Hauax. Du meinst, das ist Bärchensalami? Nee, die Bärchensalami, die schmeckt wirklich am besten. Wenn die so aussieht wie Bärchen, dann ist es so ein bisschen. Ja, das stimmt, dann kann man die nicht in die Ohren abbeissen. Ja, genau, kann man auch auch noch beissen. Es gibt folgende Honigsorten, gibt es eine Menge. Waldhonig, Blütenhonig, Rapshonig, Akazienhonig, Lindenhonig, Tannenhonig, Fichtenhonig. Leute, gebt denen mal vernünftige Namen, ey, gebt denen mal Blue Thunder oder Paradise. Jetzt kommt das erste Coole, Sommertrachthonig, Kleehonig, Heidehonig, Buchweizenhonig, Löwenzahnhonig. Ja mein Gott, das ist doch langweilig, gebt denen mal Blue Raspberry oder Thunderquake oder sowas, Earthquake oder Juicy Fruit oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Juicy fucking, ja, wie, ja, Stachelhonig.
Sweet Tornado, Honey Bun, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, irgendwie Cinnamon Bee Honig, Stung by Bee Honey, People died for this honey. People lost their lives for this honey. Oh, Jesus. Das fände ich besser. Es gibt diesen einen guten Honig, der irgendwo in, keine Ahnung, Südamerika irgendwo, haben Joko und Klaas auch mal gemacht, die waren dann mal da, haben an so einer Felswand. Welchen Honig haben die eigentlich noch nicht gegessen, oder? Das kann doch nicht sein. Ja, es zieht sich ein bisschen durch. Aber die haben von so einer Felswand, da ist so ein Honig, so ein Bienenvolk, und die ernähren sich da nur von giftigen Blüten irgendwie und verbauen die zu Honig. Und wenn das Menschen wiederum konsumieren, diesen Honig, dann hat das so bewusstungserweiterte, Ayahuasca-artige Dinge. Und das hat Joko genehmen müssen. Und der musste den noch selber, weil er auch Rhönangst hat, auch ein großes Problem, den selber pflücken von so einer Felswand. Das ist natürlich cool. Hier die Bienen hingegen, ja, dann schnuppern die ein bisschen nach einer Akazie und dann hat sie alles so ein bisschen so ein ... Aber kann man das nicht künstlicher machen? Also kann man nicht einfach irgendwie da so künstliche Blüten generieren, wo man mal so Cola-Geschmack reintut oder so und dann kommen die Bienen und bestäuben das und machen dann da Cola-Honig drauf? Also das ist ja nicht so schwer. Ich meine, wir füttern doch alle Tiere mit irgendwelchen Sachen. Ich meine, als ob Hühner nicht auch Futter bekommen, damit die Hühner selber besser schmecken oder die Eier oder keine Ahnung. So, dass da auch so ein bisschen Kirschgeschmack drin ist oder so. Das finde ich sehr gut, ja. Warum kann man denn das bei Bienen nicht machen? Die sind ja, glaube ich, relativ simpel. Du gibst denen ja so Zuckerwasser und dann machst du denen halt so ein bisschen so Bubblegum-Geschmack irgendwie an die Innenblüte ran. Ich meine, Stefan, langfristig müssen wir über künstliche Befruchtungssysteme nachdenken, weil die Bienen hauen ab. Die haben keinen Bock mehr. Die sind raus. Die sagen, wisst ihr was, wir haben jetzt
ein Jahrmillionen euren Scheiss bestäubt,
ihr macht den Scheiss jetzt alleine, okay?
Wir haben keinen Bock mehr.
Wie machen die das genau? Also die fliegen,
weil das hat neulich ein Kumpel
gesagt, und das stimmt,
man sagt bei Kindern, wenn man denen das
erklärt, wie das...
Bleist sich wie eine Biene. Ne, ne, genau, wenn man sagt,
immer macht man ja
das Gespräch mit der Blume und der Biene,
kommt dann irgendwann, wenn es um Sex geht,
im ersten Aufklärung.
Im Englischen ja the birds and the bees,
was überhaupt keinen Sinn ergibt.
Die fressen sich.
Also die haben nichts miteinander zu tun.
Mama, Papa, ihr fress euch, ihr habt nichts miteinander zu tun, das stimmt.
Die stehen auf dem grossen Tierempfang nebeneinander und schweigen.
Ja.
Bienen und Vögel so. Ah, ihr könnt auch fliegen? Ja. Aber auf eine ganz andere Art. Ja. Mögt ihr, ähm, mögt ihr Blüten? Ähm, nee, nicht besonders. Okay. Also Kolibris, ja, ich bin jetzt nicht, ich kenne Kolibris. Kolibris lieben Blüten, ja. Und, ähm, habt ihr eine Königin? Ah, okay, ja klar. Dann warte ich hier. Ich gehe hinten zu dem sehr leckeren Hirsen. Ja, bedien dich, ne? Ist auch, glaube ich, nervig. Generell bei Tieren, Verständigungsprobleme und dann so awkward silence. Ich konnte es nicht angucken. Wir haben mal ein guter Arbeitssketsch gedreht auf so einem Bauernhof mit Pferden. Und dann stand ich am Rand von diesem Pferdebereich und ich konnte es nicht ertragen. Weil die haben einfach awkward silence den ganzen Tag. Die Pferde, die stehen nebeneinander und kauen und niemand macht mal so ein ... Ja, ja. Ganz schnell geht nicht. Ich habe mich nämlich in Wien in so ein Café gesetzt und das war genau an so einer Viaker-Haltestelle. Das sind Kutschen, muss man das wahrscheinlich für unsere deutschen Kollegen sagen. Völlig richtig, das sind Kutschen, die das Stadtbild von Wien prägen. Aber auch ein bisschen umstritten sind, weil sind die Pferde nicht so gesund. Ich bin nicht der, ich kann es nicht bewerten. Wie viele Beine sollten die eigentlich haben? Ich meine, die hatten jetzt zwei. Ich weiß nicht, sind Pferde so aus, die sahen aus wie auf so einem schlecht gelaufenen Panoramabild. Naja, jedenfalls, die beiden Pferde standen dann nebeneinander, und es sind immer zwei, die werdenbeneinander eingeteilt. Genau. Wonach das kommt, verstehen die sich gut, I don't know, hat jedenfalls nicht so ausgesehen. Dann stehen die nebeneinander und es ist ja nicht so, dass man wie Vögel, die zwitschern oder Hunde, die bellen oder aneinander riechen oder sowas. Bei denen hat man nichts gesehen, was irgendwie Kommunikation aussagt. Die stehen nebeneinander und sagen nichts. Die haben ja auch diese Scheuklappen, die sehen ja gar nicht nach links und rechts. Das hilft aber ein bisschen, das ist weniger peinlich, finde ich. Ja. Alles ist weniger peinlich, weil es ist so wie so ein Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer, wie so zwei Menschen, die man im Zug beobachtet, die so bei der Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer aufdenken, okay, eigenes Business. Genau. Das hilft ein bisschen dieser Awkwardness, dass sie Scheuklappen aufbekommen haben. Total. Wahrscheinlich war das auch die Idee der Pferde, die gesagt haben, du, wir stehen hier neun Stunden am Tag in Awkward Silence nebeneinander. Entweder wir kriegen Walkman oder zumindest so Barrieren zwischen uns, dass wir uns nicht sehen, so wie beim Pissoir oder so, dass man einfach so eine Mauer hat. Ja, okay, dann kriegt ihr so Scheuklappen. Ich habe schon einen perfekten Titel dafür. Wir müssen trotzdem eure Weigen ziehen? Ja, okay. Das ist irgendwie euer Ding. Weiß ich gar nicht. Er ist auf der Prärie so allein unterwegs. Ja, ja, gut, aber es ist er wie gemacht für. Das stimmt, ja. Das kann man leider nicht, das ist unser Talent. Es ist aber sehr gesprächig dafür, dass du mit Joe nie sprichst. Ja, du weißt, nach vier Wochen hat man irgendwie alles durch. So Hufeisenpflege ist halt auch ein beschränktes Thema. Nee, aber lass uns doch mal anfangen mit dem Hufeisen und dann vielleicht mal nächste Woche über eine Gewerkschaft nachdenken. Langfristig, langfristig, langfristig. Ich sehe die Stirn runzeln, ich sehe es, ich sehe es, aber okay, nächste Woche dann. Hufeisen ist das nicht der, ich werfe Schuhe langfristig. Dass wir eure Menschenschuhe tragen? Nee. Nee, vergiss es. Okay. Vergiss es. Weil, na ja, es wäre süss, auf der Art, wenn die meine Menschenschuhe tragen können. Wir sind auch immer schon eigene denkende Wesen, also wir sind nicht euer Spielzeug, ne, sowas, also, ne? Hat man eigentlich ... Naja, ne, also, gut, was machst du mit der Peitsche jetzt? Naja, lauf doch mal schneller ein bisschen. Schlag mich. Ich wusste, du willst es auch. Ich wusste, du willst es auch. Aber es stimmt, es tragen die keine Schuhe? Warum tragen die nicht Rollschuhe oder so? Weil es ist ja offensichtlich, der Mensch kann ja ... Also der Mensch ist doch effizienter mit Rollen, oder? Ja. Also allein energiemässig kommt er doch schneller voran mit Rollschuhen. Ja. Wie schwer wär's denn mal? Mal so ein paar Testpferden. Weil stell dir vor, die haben ja vier Rollschuhe an. Die haben ja vier Rollschuhe. Wie diese ICE-Mässig werden die unterwegs. Die würden ja durch die Wiener Innenstadt ballern, aber so da kommt der Vierer aber erst mal testest du erst mal nur einen Vogelstrauss. So schön zwei Inlineskates. Ja. Und den Helm auf, Helm auf, Knieschoner und dann Vogelstrauß. Oder so sieben Meilenstiefeln oder so. Einfach mal so gucken, wie weit kann man es treiben, wie weit geht es. Stelzen, Skateboard, Skateboard! Vogelstrauß Stelzen zu geben, fühlt sich lächerlich redundant aber auch an. Der sieht schon so aus wie so ein V ein V auf Elzen. Oder gibt bei Eisbären so Schlittschuhe oder sowas. Vielleicht kommen die dann noch über die Polkappen drüber, bevor es schmilzt. Eben nicht, gibt es ja ein Eis mehr. Gibt dem Schwimmflügel. Ja, dann gibt dem Jet-Skis. Gibt dem Schwimmflügel. Mein Gott, ist da nicht alles, ich muss doch nicht alles entscheiden. Gibt dem Schwimmflügel. Aber das fand ich nicht so schlecht. Pferden mal Rollschuhe ansehen und dann mal gucken, was passiert. Ich glaube, dass die ausrutschen und sich Gnicke brechen. Die haben ja neun. Gnicke werden brechen, aber die haben ja neun. Ja, das stimmt. Acht kann man brechen, danach muss man höllisch aufpassen. Ja, ja. Höllisch aufpassen. Höllisch. Dann ist der Kopf ab. Dann ist der Kopf, hängt er einfach nur noch schlaff runter. Und dann ziehen wir den Kopf an der Seite über die Straße. Das Problem, was dieser Awkwardness auch nicht hilft, ist, dass die ja die Augen auf den Seiten haben und sich eh immer schon angucken. Also wenn die nebeneinander stehen und eigentlich in eine andere Richtung gucken, zwei Augen gucken sich immer an. Das ist so unangenehm. Und die haben ja auch keine Augenlider, ne? Also die sind ja wie Eidechsen. Die sind sich ausgeliefert, doch die haben wunderschöne grosse Augen, ne die haben wunderschöne grosse Wimpern. Aber es wäre so lustig, wenn die das eine Auge zumachen, um sich nicht mehr angucken zu müssen. Aber das andere ist noch auf. Pferde sind so peinlich. Aber konzentrieren die sich dann auf eine Seite oder auf die andere? Oder sehen die wirklich konstant beide Seiten links und rechts neben ihnen? Das weiß ich nicht genau, wie es das im Gehirn dann komponiert. Aber die sehen dann nicht, was direkt vor ihnen ist, oder? Doch, ich denke schon. Aber nicht direkt vor ihnen. Also wenn man denen so einen witzigen Hut aufsetzen würde, würde ich das überhaupt nicht sehen. Wie ein Blitzscreen. Splitscreen, Entschuldigung. Wie so ein Splitscreen. Und dann in der Mitte haben die dann so einen Strich, so einen leichten. Weil das kann schon sein, dass die da nicht alles reden. Bescheuert, ey. Bescheuerte Tiere sind das. Naja, komm. Nee, komm. Absoluter Quatsch. Wir sehen ja auch dafür nicht zu weit zur Seite. Wir müssen mal so ein Kopfbild drehen, wie so ein aufgeregtes Taube. Nee, abgelehnt. Wie abgelehnt? Nee, Pferde sind peinlich, Pferde sind awkward miteinander, redlich miteinander. Wenn die dann zumindest so ein Wuuuuh! Ja, immer so ein High Five oder irgendwie so ein High-Clop oder so, dass sie wirklich sich so hinten aufbäumen und dann so High Ten. Ja, nicht, zumindest mit dem Schwanz mal so schlagen oder sowas. Apropos Tiere, wir haben ja überlegt, können Tiere lehnen?
Und da haben wir ganz viele Nachrichten bekommen.
Leaning Animals.
Und zwar, viele sagen nein, und zwar geht das so weit, dass sogar in der legendären Serie Kommissar Rex, und dafür danke ich an der Stelle nochmal André, denn der hat sich die Mühe gemacht aus der Serie Kommissarex, für alle, die es nicht wissen, ein Schäferhund löst Verbrechen. Quatsch, was ein Quatsch. Und dafür wurde dem Hund, der Kommissarex gespielt hat, beigebracht, sich anzulehnen, weil es sollte eine Szene geben, in der Kommissarex müde und gelangweilt wirkt und man hat sich gedacht, dann soll der halt so an der Wand lehnen. Und dann hat der Hundetrainer gesagt, ja, das machen Hunde nicht. Das ist ein scheiß Hund. Und dann haben die gesagt, ja, dann bring das dem doch bei. Und tatsächlich wurde dem Hund beigebracht, sich an die Wand zu lehnen. Ich zeige das Stefan jetzt. Und los geht's. Und da kann man sehen, wie der Hund an der Wand lehnt. Das sieht so gruselig aus. Wie der einfach an der Wand lehnt. Und das wurde dem extra beigebracht. Es sieht überhaupt nicht bequem aus. Es sieht aus, als wäre er einfach betrunken gelähmt gegen die Wand. Das ist ja hilarious. Er lehnt betrunken an der Wand. Aber okay, war anscheinend
Nerv getroffen zu haben, wenn
lehnende Tiere so wenig in den Dingen sind,
dass man es ihnen extra beibringen muss.
Und dann die wenigen Geschichten, wo es gelungen ist, auch bekannt sind.
Genau. Vor allem, also ist es denn
eine Möglichkeit für uns, den Tieren zu helfen?
Weil, wie wir es gerade schon angedeutet haben,
das sieht nicht so aus, als ob dem Hund
lehnen hält. Wann was sagt er,
als er aus dem beigebracht wird?
Wenn er dann so, weil er muss ja dann so, mit Hunden bekommen wir alles mit Leckerlis beigebracht. Und dann, stell dir mal vor, du nimmst den so und legst den so gegen die Wand, und er so, okay, schiebst mich gegen die Wand, nee, nee, aber deine Beine müssen weg von der Wand. Okay, es tut aber ziemlich weh. Und bitte Leckerchen. Ah, nehm, nehm, nehm, ich habe das richtig gemacht. Ich meine, wie wir es ja gleich in unserem gesellschaftskritischen Kabarettstück gerade angedeutet haben, behandeln Menschen ja Tiere nicht immer so gut. Vielleicht ist es eine Möglichkeit, was zurückzugeben. Vielleicht sollten wir von Schule zu Schule tingeln und Leuten mit unseren Kabarettstücken zeigen, wie man die Welt eigentlich leben sollte. Ja, glaube ich auch, wir könnten da viele gute Lektionen beibringen. Das ist auch, glaube ich, genau das, was die Jugend heute gerade wissen will. Und ich glaube, so kann man denen ja weiterhelfen, weil angenommen, der Hund findet es total cool, sich anzulehnen, gibt das weiter an seine Kinder und irgendwann machen das alle Hunde, sich anzulehnen. Vielleicht finden die es ja gut, vielleicht sind die nur noch nicht drauf gekommen. Ich meine, es gibt ja viele Techniken, zum Beispiel jetzt diese klassische, diese Russen-Hocke, sage ich jetzt mal.
Das ist ja auch eine Technik, die eine gewisse Kultur entwickelt hat, die vielleicht dann darüber über diese Kulturgrenzen hinausschwappt und man sagt, hey, das ist viel besser, so zu hocken, als sich hinzuknien oder so oder Schneidersitz. So auch unter Menschen, die machen ja nicht alle die gleichen Bewegungen oder sitzen gleich, sondern unterschiedliche Kulturen sitzen anders. Vielleicht kann man so den Tieren mal so ein paar Ideen geben. Jetzt vergisst du aber, dass natürlich Menschen auch Dinge machen, nicht weil es gut ist oder bequem ist, sondern weil wir Trottel sind, die Opfer unserer gesellschaftlichen Anforderungen sind. Weiter. Ich behaupte nämlich, dass Lehnen nicht gut ist. Ist gelernt. Ist gelernt. Von dem Bösewicht von Doug.
Der den Apfel kaut und an der Wand lehnt. Cool.
Wie hieß denn noch mal diese Serie?
Wie Doug?
Mit dem Grünen.
Wallace and Gromit?
Nein.
Wie hieß denn noch mal?
Mit dem Grünen?
Weirdes Flashback.
Diese Spyro, Gags, Gags 3D. Nee, Doug. Doug, ja, Doug. Hieß einfach die Serie auch Doug? Ja, die hieß Doug. Mit Patty Mayonnaise. Genau, und da gab es noch diesen Bösewicht, der immer an der Wand gelehnt hat. Ja. Naja, so. Jedenfalls, und das ist doch nur gelernt, das ist doch nicht keine bequeme Stellung, das ist einfach nur nervig, man steht ja immer noch, man will lieber sitzen. Menschen wollen lieber sitzen, Menschen können auch lieber sitzen, Hunde können auch sitzen. Würden wir jetzt diesem Hund nicht etwas beibringen, was ja gar nicht so toll ist, nur weil wir glauben, dass Lehnen eine coole Eigenschaft ist? Nee, nicht sich mal aufzwingen, sondern einfach mal die Perspektive aufzubieten. Zu sagen, pass auf, das ist vielleicht eine Möglichkeit, das ist vielleicht was, schaust dir mal an, vielleicht hast du Lust drauf. Genau, musst du nicht mehr machen. Du kriegst ein Leckerchen, ob du das jetzt weitermachen willst oder nicht. Ja, ich meine so bei Yoga oder Tai-Chi oder so, da macht man ja auch Tierposen, da versucht man sich ja auch an den Tieren, so den Kranich oder so, sagen wir mal, vielleicht hat der eine gute Idee. Warum denn nicht mal sagen, vielleicht haben andere auch gute Ideen, das ist ja alles, was ich sage. Ich glaube nur, nach meinen Yoga-Erfahrungen, dass der Kran nicht deutlich bewirklicher ist und für andere Positionen gemacht wird als ich. Der hat weniger Rückenschmerzen als ich. Der hat weniger Rückenschmerzen als ich. Der hat gelenkiger als ich. Ich meine, dass wir Menschen nicht immer nur nehmen, nehmen, nehmen und von den Tieren uns irgendwie den Leopardenschal um den Hals hängen, sondern dass wir denen auch mal was zurückgeben. Dass wir mal sagen, wollt ihr nicht Kaffee trinken? Das ist unsere Idee. Wie wir uns von den Vogelskreussen abgeschaut haben, wie die sich Leoparden Schals ummachen. Stimmt, das haben wir uns abgeguckt. Ja, ich finde es super. Lass uns denen mal Sachen sagen. Lass uns denen mal zeigen, hier übrigens so schmeckt so schmeckt Zucker zum Beispiel in wenn du das überall drauf machst, oder Salz. Mal zeigen, wie geil eigentlich alles besser ist mit Salz. Mal so einen Löwen. Mal schönen Glutamat. Ja, genau. Und die Antilope so, what the, wow! Jam, jam, jam, jam, jam, jam, jam, jam, jam, jam, jam, jam, jam, jam, jam, jam. Löwen mal zeigen, wie geil das Stück Fleisch da noch schmeckt, wenn es ein bisschen angebraten ist. Ja. Bisschen Salz, ein bisschen angebraten. Oh, herrlich. Und dann so schön in Streifen geschnitten. Ja, ach nein, ja, nein. Ich weiß nicht, ob man den Tieren, unseren Menschen scheißt. Vor allem, wir gehen die eh kaputt. Wie geht es deinem Rücken? Geht es da besser? Ja, Rücken ist jetzt besser. Dafür bricht alles andere zusammen. Ich mache jetzt mein Rückentraining gewissenhaft jeden Tag, wahrscheinlich noch diese Woche, danach nie wieder, weil sobald ich das Problem nicht mehr sinnlich wahrnehme, existiert es nicht mehr. Richtig. Und dann geht's irgendwann wieder los. Aber dann mach doch jetzt mal, wie ich mir das vorgenommen habe, mach dir mal die Notiz in dein Handy. Jeder Tag ohne Rückenschmerzen ist ein Bonustag. Das ist mein Bildschirnhintergrund, jetzt mein Neuer. Das machst du jetzt mal als Bildschirnhintergrund. Ihr setzt Liedermar Landrut durch diesen Satz oder was? Genau. Jeder Tag ohne Rückenschmerzen ist ein wunderbarer Tag. Weil, das habe ich mir vorgenommen, weil man weiß gar nicht, wie toll Tage sind, wo man keine Schmerzen hat, wenn man keine Schmerzen hat. Wenn du Schmerzen hast, merkst du das. Weil dann, da weiss man es wirklich zu. Ich wusste nicht mehr, wie man jemals glücklich war. Ich wusste nicht, war ich jemals glücklich, kann ich nicht, wenn man es glücklich sein. Mit diesen nervigen Rückschmerzen, die du in jeder Position hast. Der ist beim Sitzen, der ist beim Lehnen, der ist beim Liegen, überall. Und ich glaube, was auch ein Problem ist, man kriegt kein Mitleid. Weil andere können es nicht sehen. Rückenschmerzen. Wenn jetzt dir so ein Pfeil im Bauch steckt und dann sagst du, das tut weh und alle sagen, ja, das sieht echt schmerzhaft aus. Und wie ist das passiert? Nein, wie ist das passiert? Aber das sieht wirklich schmerzhaft aus. Wo hast du dich rumgetriegt? Du tust mir so leid.
Nein, alle würden sagen, what the fuck, warum steckt ein Pfeil in deiner Brust?
Wohingegen, wenn du Rückenschmerzen hast, dann sagt man, stell dich nicht so an.
Was hast du? Weil man humpelt ja auch nicht.
Ich habe halb gehumpelt, aber auch nur so, weil ich dachte, dann fragen sich Leute nicht,
dann sagen die, ah, der ist verletzt. Ist das der schlimmste Satz der Welt, stell dich nicht so an? Ich finde, das ist einer der schlimmsten Sätze der Welt, stell dich nicht so an. Wie oft haben Leute schon gesagt, ah stimmt, du hast recht, ich höre auf, mich jetzt anzustellen. Ich stimme ja. Bisher stellte ich mich an, bis jetzt, jetzt wird sich nicht mehr angestellt, jetzt ist alles wieder in Ordnung. Ich verstehe es auch deutsch nicht. Sich anstellen, etwas zu tun gibt es ja. Ganz merkwürdiger Satz, ja. Aber das ist ja nicht das. Wie? Es gibt ja anstellen im Sinne von in einer Schlange stehen. Ja, ja, nee, das ist damit nicht gemeint. Das ist damit nicht gemeint. Dann gibt es die andere Bedeutung von anstellen, sich anstellen, etwas zu tun. Ja. Ich stelle mich an, mich da vorne in die Schlange zu stellen. Nicht der beste Beispielsatz. Jetzt stell dich nicht so an und stell dich an. Genau. Vor der Kinokasse. Nee, das macht keinen Sinn. Doch, vor der Kinokasse kannst du sagen, jetzt hör auf, dich anzustellen und stell dich an. Und dann sagst du ja, ich stelle mich jetzt mal an, mich da anzustellen. Ja. Es gibt drei Bedeutungen. Und die dritte verstehe ich nicht. Nämlich, stell dich nicht so an. Sich anstellen. Das sagt er sonst nicht. Das sagt er nur in diesem Satz so. Du kannst ja nicht sagen, nee, ich stelle mich jetzt mal an. Eigentlich müsste man das mal wieder zurückerobern und sagen, nee, heute stelle ich mich an. Heute stelle ich mich an. Heute ist ein Tag an, ich stelle mich an. Man kann das nicht so benutzen. Man kann das wirklich nur in diesem einen Satz mit der Bedeutung benutzen. Diese eine Bedeutung, du schauspielst dich in etwas, du tust so, als wäre etwas schlimmer als es ist. Wahrscheinlich gibt es da irgend so ein indogermanisches, uraltes Wort, das da noch irgendwie mit reinschwingt und wir kriegen das gar nicht mit. Stellere, stellere, stellere, stellere, so und das schwingt da immer noch mit von so einem Vorfahren. Bist du in dieser ... Stellst du dich an? Ich stelle mich tierisch an. Aber vor wem? Wenn du dann so alleine zu Hause Rückenschmerzen hast? Nee, ich bin weinerlich. Ich bin weinerlich und ich übertreibe negative Dinge, damit ich Mitleid bekomme. Und wenn auf der Strasse mir irgendwie ein Stein im Schuh ist, dann spiele ich das ganz gross und wieder ich und alle damit alle Mitleid mit mir haben. Ah nein, jetzt habe ich mich angehauen. Und es ist einfach ganz schrecklich. Ich bin ganz, ganz, ganz weinerliches, mimosenhaftes Wichtchen. Bist du eigentlich in dieser Bibi-Sache mit drin? Gar nicht mit drin.
Bibi, eine der berühmtesten deutschen YouTuberinnen. Das weiß ich. Mit Julienko. Genau, also ich habe die schon verfolgt. Die haben mir jemanden in ihr Haus gezeigt, habe ich mir mit großer Freude angeguckt damals. Die haben sich getrennt. Im Neo-Magazin haben wir immer viel darüber gesprochen. Genau, die haben sich getrennt. Getrennt? Entschuldigung. Die haben sich getrennt. Und tatsächlich ist, weil Bilder aufgetaucht sind von ihr mit einem anderen Mann.
Und seitdem ist die ganze Szene in Aufruhr.
Genau.
Weil man muss das ein bisschen in den Kontext setzen und ich finde es fantastisch.
Denn kurz bevor diese Skandalfotos kamen und die Beziehung in die Brüche gegangen ist, haben die beiden, die haben einen Podcast und die haben in ihrem Podcast gesagt,
wir machen bald ein
großes soziales Experiment.
Was schon mal toll ist, was aber
finde ich noch viel besser ist, dass sie auch
ein Stück davor
haben sie nach Doppelgängern gesucht.
Also
sie wollten Doppelgänger haben,
was erstmal finde ich der beste
Move der Welt ist. Weil, also generell erstmal immer nach Doppelgänger haben, was erstmal finde ich der beste Move der Welt ist.
Weil, also generell, erstmal immer nach Doppelgängern suchen, damit egal was danach passiert, du kannst immer sagen, ja wir haben ja extra diesen Doppelgängeraufruf gemacht. Es ist fantastisch. Und das, und diese Dinge, weil alle, niemand kann jetzt über diese Beziehung hinwegkommen von den Fans, weil alle noch denken, Moment mal, da ist doch noch was, obwohl beide schon gesagt haben, darüber würden wir nie Pranks machen und sowas in der Richtung, aber es ist natürlich schwierig, das einzuordnen. Man kann emotional noch nicht loslassen, weil wir denken, ist das jetzt ein Doppelgänger, der das sagt, ist die Person, die sagt, es war kein Prank ein Doppelgänger, bin ich ein Doppelgänger? Was geschieht überhaupt? Also es ist ein riesiges Gewirr von Lügen.
Was erwarten Leute für ein Sozialexperiment? Dass wenn Fotos auftauchen mit Leuten von einem anderen Mann, dass sich wahrscheinlich immer getrennt hat und dass dann, wenn dann Julienko in die Kamera sagt, wir haben uns getrennt, was ist das für ein Experiment? Das Experiment ist, wir machen unsere Karriere kaputt, um dann, ja, also muss man noch gucken, aber das ist schon mal genial, vor allem, das ist ja, vor allem, angenommen, ich würde fremdgehen, das erste, was ich machen würde, ist, ich würde versuchen, Doppelgänger um mich zu scharen und das auch medienwirksam zu verkünden, zu sagen, ah, falls ihr so aussieht wie ich, meldet euch mal, wir brauchen ganz viele Doppelgänger, so dass du ab dann immer sagen kannst, das bin nicht ich, das ist mein Doppelgänger. Das ist ja absolut fantastisch. Und niemand weiß, was los ist. Und alle Bilder, jetzt kommen immer Bilder von A, hat er eine neue? Oder wie ist es, sind sie wieder zusammen, sie sitzen in seinem Restaurant? Und es können halt alles auch immer Doppelgänger sein. Weil niemand weiß, was hier passiert. Ist es jetzt ein neuer Typ mit einem Bibi-Doppelgänger, ist es ein Bibi-Doppelgänger und ein Julian-Doppelgänger gleichzeitig? Sind es die echten? Niemand weiß, was los ist, weil überall diese Doppelgänger rumlaufen. Das ist sehr lustig. Wenn ihr shady Sachen vorhabt in der Zukunft, besorgt euch Doppelgänger, weil ihr seid aus dem Schneider, ihr seid fein raus. Das ist interessant. Generell, alle eure Taten jetzt können vor Gericht irgendwann mal benutzt werden. Schreibt jede Nachricht so mit dem Bewusstsein, dass man irgendwann vor Gericht benutzt werden kann. Seid nett zueinander.
Das ist ein Hack.
Seid nett zueinander, weil wenn das Vorgericht mal irgendwann kommt, dann seht ihr netter aus.
Dann glaubt euch die Jury mehr.
Genau, denkt immer, eine unabhängige Jury würde mitlesen und ihr wollt deren Sympathie, weil du willst nicht zum Tode verurteilt werden. Genau. Und im Zweifel soll dich Peter umbringen.
Nein, es kann gegen mich verwendet werden.
Clever, smart, smart, sei kein Klinieller.
Ich würde ihm doch nie ein Haar grümmen.
Sehr clever, seid nett zueinander, seid cool miteinander, denn dann seid ihr vor Gericht auch die coolsten.
Smart, ne? Guter Ansatz, schöner Ansatz. So sollten wir in Schulen gehen, dass wir einfach sagen, vergesst mal gerade Kant, vergesst mal gerade Religion, habt ihr diese Amber Heard-Nummer mitbekommen? Scheiße, da muss ich mich auch gerade drinnen, weil das, wo ich laut lachen musste von meinem YouTube-Channel war nämlich, als dann irgendwann Beweismittel zugelassen wurden, und zwar, was sie sich geschenkt haben. Und Amber Hurt hat ja Johnny Depp der häuslichen Gewalt angeklagt und er der Verleumdung und dann beide Verleumdungsprozesse. Blablabla. Und dann hat irgendwann die im Kreuzverhör die Anwälte von Johnny Depp gefragt, was haben sie Johnny Depp geschenkt zu seinem Geburtstag. Und sie hat ihm ein Riesenmesser geschenkt. So ein Katana-artiges, ein Riesenmesser. Und dann, alles klar, ja, wir haben es hier. Und es war genau in dem Jahr, wo halt diese Vorwürfe im Raum standen. Und dann bringt die dieses Messer vorhin zu Jury und zeigt das so. Und es ist einfach so ein riesen gefährliches, martialisches Ich-schlag-mir-den-Weg-durch-den-Dschungel-Messer, wo unten dann noch irgendwie eine kleine Botschaft eingraviert wurde oder sowas. Aber so riesig. Und es fällt einem natürlich so auf die Füsse. Und da muss man auch aufpassen, was schenkt man wem wann. Deswegen auch hier, schenkt immer so, dass ihr das von der Jury immer noch gut in welche Geschichte auch immer einpacken könnt. Aber schenkt vor allem was. Ja, ein Pogostick. Weil so schlecht könnte er ja nicht sein, wenn ihr vor Gericht immer beweisen könnt, dass ihr was geschenkt habt.
Gott, wie schrecklich das ist. Ich würde sofort schuldig plädieren, wenn die da anfangen, irgendwie Geschenke. Und wann genau kam das Geschenk? Aha, das ist ja nicht genau der Geburtstag, oder? Ach Gott. Ja, ist ja gut. Ich war's. Du weißt es nicht, aber das Kartenhaus will, fällt zusammen, das soziale Kartenhaus, Kartenwrack will, weil du zu spät schenkst, Geburtstage vergisst und so. War es es am Ende nicht, war es für eine Lappalie angezeigt, über Rotgehen hast du da vor Gericht gesessen, drei Monate lang, aber am Ende bist du für alles schuldig, weil rauskommt, was man für, bei mir auch, was man für ein schlechter Mensch ist. Was man für ein schlechter Mensch ist. Ich habe gehört, in den USA ist es völlig normal, dass man auch in der Woche, bevor jemand Geburtstag hat, schon alles Gutes zum Geburtstag sagt. In Deutschland geht das ja gar nicht, da darf man nicht vor dem Tag. Big No-No hier. Aber in den USA ist das kein Problem. Hier ist großes No. Kannst auch gerne, egal wann, kannst auch sechs Monate später noch schreiben. Das ist in Südafrika. In Südafrika kannst du alles sagen. Das ganze Jahr eigentlich. Man darf sich das ganze Jahr da beschenken. Das ist viel besser eigentlich. Ist es peinlicher, jemanden zum Geburtstag zu gratulieren, wenn er so überhaupt gar nicht Geburtstag hat, oder eine Woche zu spät? Nee, ich finde ja eigentlich nicht so schlecht. Nee, irgendwann finde ich besser. Weil das sagt so, stell dir mal vor, aus völligem Selbstbewusstsein sagst du jetzt zu irgendwem, hey, alles gut zum Geburtstag, dann kommst du zurück, ich habe heute nicht Geburtstag. Und dann sagst du, hast du ja heute mit dem Kalender, weil das suggeriert so, ah, du interessierst dich für diese Person. Wirklich, das suggeriert doch nur, dass du einfach nach Kalender gehst. Naja, aber das ist ja sowieso so. Du reisst heute gesellschaftliche Mauern ein. Das sagt doch aus. Du bist heute mit der sozialen Abrissbirne unterwegs. Du hast schon recht. Watch out. Es sagt ja zumindest aus, ich habe mir einen Kalendereintrag gemacht. Du bedeutest mir so viel, ich habe mir für dich einen jährlichen Kalendereintrag gemacht. Das ist das Netteste, was je jemand, jemand für mich. Du hast schon recht. Ich habe gar nicht, diese Option war gar nicht in meinem Kopf vorhanden, dass man sich einfach merken kann, weil jemand Geburtstag hat. Aber du musst dann auch ein Geschenk dabei haben, so richtig eingepackt, du alles Geburtstag zum Geburtstag, du kriegst Geschenk und dann so. Ich glaube vor allem, ich würde einfach alles akzeptieren und überhaupt nicht auflösen und von wegen, ich habe gar nicht. Danke. Dankeschön. Wunderbar. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, wann du Geburtstag hast. Ich auch nicht. Du weißt auch nicht, wann du Geburtstag hast? Grob. Du bist der Mensch, der mir am nächsten steht, vor dem ich nicht weiss, wann er Geburtstag hat. Das ist nett. Das freut mich. Aber das auch nicht, sagen Leute, oh Stefan, du bist so ein Arschloch, warum weißt du nicht, wenn du Geburtstag hast. Nein, nein, nicht jeder mag seinen Geburtstag. Florentin mag das nicht, Florentin sagt es nicht gern. Ich bin hier der Heilige, Florentin ist der Weird. Nee, aber ich verstehe das auch, ich bin auch kein großer Fan. Aber noch schlimmer als ein Geburtstag ist ein Geburtstag, an dem niemand einem schreibt. Ach ja, aber dafür habe ich immer noch das Filmfehlerforum. Das Filmfehlerforum, wo ich mich vor zwölf Jahren angemeldet habe, das schickt mir immer noch jedes Jahr herzlichen Glückwunsch, automatisierte Mail. Und da weiss ich einfach, hey, das ist eine Konstante in meinem Leben, die wird zu schnell nicht mehr weggenommen. Ich habe damals einen Thread eröffnet, dass die Elben in Helmsklamm die falsche Bogenschusstechnik haben, in meinen Augen war das ein Filmfehler
damals, als ich 14 war.
Und nicht mit Maura Labinki
unterschrieben wurde.
Und seitdem bekomme ich jedes Jahr
ein Hey, alles Gutes, sind gut,
sag du pedantisches Arschloch.
Aber wie hätten die in deiner Meinung nach
schießen sollen? Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau,
wir haben das auch, glaube ich, auch mal vorgelesen im Podcast,
irgendwie war die Ellbogenhaltung
war anscheinend falsch und ich
Er ist ein, was wir uns da bewegt haben. Ach so, gemessen an Menschenstandards und heutige, wie man normalerweise schießt, Standards haben die da falsch geschossen. Ja, ich kann mich da gar nicht mehr genau hininteressern, was das Problem war. Ich dachte gerade, du beschwerst dich, dass die für Waldelben merkwürdig schießen. Das habe ich gerade gedacht. Ja, irgendwie glaube ich, habe ich auch gesagt, dass ich glaube, dass die ihre Bögen zu leicht ziehen, dass da zu wenig Widerstand ist. Wo ich dann auch geschrieben habe, ja, vielleicht sind die halt super stark. Ja, es sind Waldelben. Aber irgendwie war ich nicht überzeugt. Das ist ein blatter Bullshit, ey. Ich glaube, das sind meine Jugendsünden, da schäme ich mich echt dafür für Filmfehlerforum. Deswegen versuche ich heute, möglichst alles durchzuwinken an Filmfehlern. Ich versuche, meine Sünden wieder gutzumachen. Immer wenn im Film irgendein Fehler ist, sage ich, kein Problem, passt, da wird es eine Erklärung geben, weiter! Jetzt bin ich viel zu liberal. Ich übersehe, ich springe mit einem grossen Stab über jedes Plothole drüber, das sich mir bietet. Kinotip, Everything Everywhere, All at Once. Hast du das auch gesehen? Auch gesehen, stark irre, endlich mal wieder ein Kinoerlebnis, endlich mal wieder ein Original-Film mit sehr, sehr viel Liebe und irgendwie, man merkt, da schwingt Liebe zum Genre mit und das ist alles ganz toll. Schaut's euch an. Irre, irre, irre. Nicht vorher informieren. Hast du noch einen Songtipp? Nicht informieren, einfach reingehen. Songtipp? Ähm, nein. Es wurde Olaf Scholz als Arroganz ausgelegt, als irgendwer meinte, haben Sie auch Haushaltstipps wie Robert Habeck und er hat gesagt, nein, und dann habe ich nur gelesen, bei so einem Artikel, es wurde ihm als Arroganz ausgelegt, weil er ihm nichts eingefallen. Dass man so Zitronen zu den Äpfeln legen soll, damit die länger halten oder was?? Oder welche Art von Haushaltstipp? Oder Staatshaushalt, oder was ist damit gemeint?
Mein Songtipp ist generell alles neue von der Band Muse.
Viel Spaß mit der Band Muse.
Wir hören einmal kurz rein in den Titelsong Don't You Love Me, Don't, Please Don't, Never Do. Don't, Never Do, Listen to Other Bands. Das war das Stück, das leider aus Copyrightgründen rausgeschnitten wurde. Falls ihr so aussieht wie Stefan Tietze, meldet euch. Stefan braucht dringend Doppelgänger, er braucht dringend, dringend Doppelgänger, er kann mittlerweile nicht mehr überall selber sein, Er braucht für Amtsgänge, Passfotos oder sowas braucht er Doppelgänger. Ja, nach allen Hörerinnen und Hörern, Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauern und Leserinnen und Lesern bin ich ja eh das austauschbarste Gesicht der Welt, weil Fanart immer nur ein Typ mit Brille ist, weil Leute, die so aussehen wie ich immer nur ein Typ mit Brille ist.
Ich trete nicht Typ mit Brille ist, weil Leute, die so aussehen
wie ich, immer nur ein Typ mit Brille ist.
Ich trete nicht mal mehr Brille,
hab nicht mal mehr Bart. Spiel nicht mehr
mit Knete. Spiel nicht mehr mit Knete.
Von daher
glaube ich, brauche ich
nicht so dringend, aber ich fände es schon super, da kann ich
machen, was ich will. Folgende Idee für einen Film.
Du bist
jetzt der Tele5-Chef, ich pitche den Film. Okay, pass auf. Der Film heißt... Warum duzen Sie mich? Passen Sie auf. Ach so. Passen Sie auf, passen mal auf. Hören Sie mal, hören Sie mal. Der Film heisst ...
Ja gut, Titel habe ich jetzt noch nicht. Okay, ist ja nicht so schlimm, fangen Sie einfach an.
Akt eins, fangen wir oben an mit der Geschichte und hören unten auf, ne?
Der Film heisst Look-Alike.
Okay.
Und wir haben einen unerfolgreichen Schauspieler, der aber zufälligerweise so aussieht wie ein erfolgreicher Schauspieler.
Und er ist immer bei Castings und er kriegt die Rolle schon fast, bis es auffällt,
Moment mal, Sie sind ja gar nicht der Schauspieler, dann wird er wieder rausgeschossen.
Ist er gar nicht Derrick Hendricks.
Genau, er ist nicht Derrick Hendricks, er ist nur Flow Me Rider.
Flow Me Rider ist nicht Derrick Hendricks, Arbeitstitel, das ist der Untertitel.
Und Flow Me Rider geht auf Castings und hält sich für richtig gut als Schauspieler, kommt auch immer weit in den Castings, fliegt dann aber raus. So, währenddessen wird der Film parallel erzählt von Derrick Ryder. Hendricks. Derrick Hendricks, der ein erfolgreicher Schauspieler ist, immer tolle Rollen hat, irgendwie am Catering-Set. Und jetzt sagt Flomi Ryder, sagt ich hab da keinen Bock mehr drauf, das ist demütigend, immer verwechselt zu werden. Ich arbeite jetzt als Doppelgänger, als Double von Derrick Hendricks. Derrick Hendricks. Und dann Ja, das ist eine lustige Buddy-Komödie dann. Und dann stirbt plötzlich Derrick Hendricks. Nee, um es kurz abzugucken, ich dachte, die Idee wäre, dass langfristig Flow Me Rider erfolgreicher wird als Derrick Hendricks und irgendwann sich das Verhältnis umdreht. Und irgendwann Derrick Hendricks, der das Double von Flow Me Rider ist, aber andersrum, als es davor war. Ich dachte, die machen dann so eine Körpertauschkomödie, dass sie dann, weshalb bei so einer Wahrsagerin, können sie ihre sehr ähnlichen Körper mit ihren eh schon ähnlichen Professionen tauschen und wachen am nächsten Morgen in ihrem Körper von Derek Hendricks slash Flow Me Rider auf. Beide Rollen werden von Guido Kanz gespielt. Beide Rollen werden. Beide Rollen, also maximal verwirrend, die tauschen, obwohl sie davor schon ähnlich aussagen, auch einen identischen Charakter haben. Ja, und die gleiche Stimme auch haben. Die gleiche Stimme. Identischer Charakter und den gleichen Beruf auch. Ja. Der eine ist ein bisschen weniger erfolgreich, aber auch nicht viel. Derrick Hendricks hat auch schon die besten Jahre hinter sich. Und dann kommt aber Derrick Hendricks im ganz schweren Unfall, verliert Finger. Und jetzt muss Flomi Ryder natürlich entscheiden. Okay, jetzt wird's Prestige einfach, okay. Ist er bereit, sich diese Finger, ist er bereit, ist Flomi Ryder bereit, sich die Finger zu nehmen? Wir haben eine ganz dramatische Szene, er an der Brotschneidemaschine, traut er sich, den Finger abzunehmen? Und dann kommt der grosse Wendepunkt im Film. Und dann geht es anders weiter und dann am Ende treffen die sich und merken, wow, im Leben geht es doch um mehr als immer nur, wer ist jetzt von uns der Erfolgreichere und wer nicht und wer ist wessen Dubel und so. Sondern es geht auch um Geld. Nee, nee, es geht auch um, was man auf dem Weg dahin gelernt hat, nicht das Ziel.
Was haben Sie auf dem Weg dahin gelernt? Viel über Biologie, also der ist dann auf so einem Community College und so, wo man dann sagt, so krass, egal wie erfolgreich ich bin, ich bin Majose und Mitose, das bleibt immer gleich. Die machen immer ihre Sachen. Und auch im Körper, ob du jetzt erfolgreich bist oder nicht, die Zellen teilen sich. In deinem Körper wie in dem von Derek Hendricks. Und das, liebe 7b des Anne-Frank-Gymnasiums, das ist die Botschaft, die wir euch heute mitgeben wollen. Wir sind noch die ganze Woche da mit verschiedenen Themenschwerpunkten. Heute sagen wir euch, egal was ihr macht, Mithose und Majose ist immer gleich. Ja, vielen Dank, das waren Stefan und Florentin. Morgen um zehn geht es hier direkt weiter. Jetzt habt ihr erstmal eine kleine Pause und danach geht es weiter mit Was wir von Tieren lernen können. Da kommt ein Känguru. Da kommt dieses unnahbare Känguru, was ein ganz anderes Leben führt und man nichts auf sich übertragen kann. Das Kette rauchende Känguru, das schon den zwanzigsten Auftritt an der Woche macht. Ja, genau. Und dann bin ich dran. Wie alt sind die Kinder? So zwölf bis vierzehn. Okay. Also nicht die richtig harten Sachen, oder? Haben sie getrunken? Es ist eine Fahne. Ja, wo muss ich hin? Da auf die Bühne. Okay. Hallo Kinder! Hi, Kangoo. Australien ist einfach eine Freakshow. Da ist nur so ein Quatsch entstanden, weil es so jahrelang isoliert war. Jahrmillionen haben sich da weirde Tiere entwickelt, das ist einfach eine merkwürdige... Wäre das eine Show? Du nimmst ein Tier aus Europa, wirklich so eine ganz weiche Hauskatze. So eine weiche mit so einem kleinen Herzglöckchen um den Hals und stellst die nach Australien und wenn sie eine Woche überlebt, dann kriegt sie was Besonderes. Leckerli. Und dann kriegt sie ein Leckerli und wahrscheinlich überlebt sie nicht, weil du hast dann diese kleine Schnuffi, die kleine weiße Puschelkatze, die dann da durchgeht und um sie herum kommt. Ja, und dann kommt so ein Drei-Meter-Skorpion, der einfach nur,
wo dann irgendwann hängt die Schnuffi an diesem Riesenstachel dran.
Und dann kommt ein riesiger Geier, so ein Mönchsgeier,
19 Meter Spannweite, der den Skorpion in der Luft zerfetzt.
Und dann kommt Tyrannosaurus Rex und sagt,
Ach, heute ist wieder viel los. Hat jemand meine Kontaktlinsen gesehen? Heute ist zu viel los. Ich will wieder heim. In diesem Sinne wünschen wir euch eine fantastische Woche. Haut rein, dass wir Folge 316 machen Haken hinten ran. Ja, endlich mal einen Haken der 316, hab ich mir gedacht. Ähnlich haben wir die hinter uns.
Ab jetzt wird's leicht, wir hoffen,
dass ihr auch nächste Woche wieder mit euch seid. Wenn es wieder
heisst, Stefan und Florentin im Podcast-Ufo,
bis dahin heben wir ab, macht es gut. Und macht es gut.
Schöne Woche, ciao.